สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีครับ Korean สวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีเช้าวันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันเสาร์ที่ไทยใช่ไหมวันเสาร์ที่ไทยค่ะ
โอเควันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
วันที่ 8
แล้วเดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนตุลาคมค่ะ
ปีพ.ศครับ
พ.ศ 2565
[เพลง]
ใช่ครับหุงข้าว 3 หุงข้าว 3 กระป๋องแล้ว
ก็คุณนิคทำแกงกะหรี่พวกแกงกะหรี่ญี่ปุ่น
น่ะที่มันซื้อเป็นกล่องแล้วก็เอาไปต้ม
เนื้ออะไรพวกนี้เคยเห็นไหมเคยกินไหมไม่
เคยกิน
หารูปภาพอ่ะอันนี้
ไม่รู้ว่าจะเห็นนะเนี่ยที่คุณนิดทำกินที่
บ้านวันนี้
[เพลง]
ไม่เคยกินเลย
ใช่ค่ะต้องส่งมาแล้วแหละ
ได้ๆเดี๋ยวส่งไปให้อาจจะสักประมาณ 3
เดือนน่าจะถึงอาจจะกลายเป็นอย่างอื่น
อาจจะเป็นโยเกิร์ตไปแล้วอาจจะเปรี้ยวๆ
หน่อยไม่หิว
ไปคุยเรื่องอื่นดีกว่าอะไรอย่างนี้
พอเวลาหิวข้าวกูเรียมีวิธียังไงที่
ทำให้หายหิวเหมือนกับจริงๆอยากกินข้าวแต่
มันมันยังไม่มีหากินไม่ได้แต่ทำยังไงให้
หายหิว
[เพลง]
ดื่มน้ำเยอะๆ
แต่ก็ถ้าเกิดมันยังหิวอยู่ก็กินเถอะ
เพราะว่าของคุณนิคเนี่ยครูนิคจะเป็นเวลา
ว่าถ้าคุณนิคหิวแต่เหมือนกับมัน 21:00 น
แล้วอ่ะยังไม่อยากนอนแล้วก็ไม่อยากกินคุณ
นิดก็จะมี 2 อย่างก็คือหาอะไรดูเหมือนจะ
ดูหนังดูทีวีหรืออีกอย่างหนึ่งก็เปิดเพลง
ฟัง
[เพลง]
เปิดเพลงฟังก็แบบฟังเพลงทั่วๆไป
ใช่ฟังเพลงทั่วๆไปให้เหมือนกับเวลามัน
ผ่านไปไวๆแล้วถ้าเรา
เบื่อหรือเริ่มรู้สึกง่วงขึ้นมาก็โอเคไป
นอน
แต่จะไม่ดูอะไรที่เป็นเกี่ยวกับอาหารเลย
ดีมากค่ะดีมากอาจจะเป็นวิธีที่ครูนิคแนะ
นำเรียน
อย่างแฟนของครูเล็กเนี่ย
เล่นเปียโนแล้วก็จะไม่หิวข้าว
คือเขาก็บอกว่าเขาก็ไม่ได้บอกว่าไม่หิว
แต่เขารู้สึกว่ามันเวลามันผ่านไปไวถ้า
ประจำมานั่งรอว่าโอ๊ยเมื่อไหร่จะได้กิน
ข้าว
ไปเล่นเปียโนดีกว่า
อ๋อถ้าแบบได้ทำอะไรที่ตัวเองชอบมันก็จะ
รู้สึกสนุกแล้วก็แบบก็เวลาผ่านไปเร็วจัง
ใช่
แล้วครูนิคเล่นดนตรีด้วยไหมคะ
คุณนิคเนี่ยไม่
[เพลง]
ใช้คำว่า
เล่นไม่เก่งดีกว่า
[เพลง]
อยากลองแต่ว่าพอลองแล้วมันก็ไม่ดีคือคุณ
นิคเนี่ยเคยเล่นกีต้าร์
เคยเล่นพวกอูคูเลเล่แล้วก็เคยอันนี้ก็จะ
เป็นตอนสมัยเรียนโรงเรียนก็จะมีเหมือนกับ
สีซอแบบนี้นะ
ครูนี้ก็อยู่ในวงดนตรีของโรงเรียนไหม
คุณนิกะไม่ได้อยู่
นายไม่ได้อยู่แต่เพื่อนคุณนิคอยู่เพื่อน
คุณนิดอยู่ในวงดนตรีของโรงเรียนเป็น
เรียมก็จำได้เลยนะว่าตอนที่เรียนเรียน
อยู่ในโรงเรียนที่โรงเรียนก็จะมีวงดนตรี
ของโรงเรียน
วงดนตรีก็จะมีคนเล่นกีต้าร์ใช่ไหมแล้วก็
มีคนเล่นเบส
แล้วก็มีคนตีกลอง
เราก็มีอะไรอีกนักร้องนักร้องนำ
ใช่นักร้องนำแต่ที่พูดมาก็เรียนไม่ได้
เกี่ยวอะไรกับวงดนตรีเลย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
หรอครับ
แต่ว่าไม่ค่อยเก่งนะคะไม่ค่อยเก่งก็เลย
แบบเล่นอยู่คนเดียว
ไม่มีวงดนตรี
ใช่แต่ว่าเวลาดูคนอื่นอ่ะตอนที่เราอยู่
อยู่ในโรงเรียนใช่ไหมคะเห็นเพื่อนแล้วก็
พี่
เล่นดนตรีเราก็จะ
เฮ้ยเก่งจังเลย
เก่งจังเลยเวลาเขามีคอนเสิร์ตไง
ใช่คนที่เล่นดนตรีหรือร้องเพลงเนี่ยก็
เวลาเราเห็นเนี่ยเราก็จะดูเท่ดี
แล้ว
ที่แบบกรี๊ดกร๊าดแบบกรี๊ดกร๊าดแบบ
เก่งจังเลยอะไรอย่างนี้
จริงๆกรี๊ดกร๊าดไหมคือคุณนิค่ะเพราะว่า
เป็นเพื่อนคุณนิดไงตอนที่วงดนตรีโรงเรียน
แล้วเราก็เรียนด้วยกันอยู่ทุกวันอยู่แล้ว
แล้วเราก็รู้อยู่แล้วว่าเออคนนี้ร้องเพลง
ได้คนนี้เล่นดนตรีได้แล้วเวลาเลิกเรียน
เราก็จะไปซ้อมดนตรีอยู่ด้วยกันทุกวันทุก
วันมันก็เลยเห็นว่าเออก็โอเคดีนะแต่ไม่
ได้กรี๊ดการ์ดเหมือนอย่างคนอื่นอีกโรง
เรียน
เรารู้จักคนนี้อยู่แล้ว
เราก็เลยแบบเออก็เพื่อนกันถามว่าดีไหมดี
เห็นเพื่อนทำดีก็โอเคแต่เราจะไม่ได้ไป
กรี๊ดเหมือนกับคนอื่นที่บางคนก็จะมีซื้อ
ของให้ด้วยนะซื้อขนมซื้อของให้แบบนี้ใช่ๆ
เป็นแบบนั้นเลยครูนิกพูดถึงเรียมหรือ
เปล่า
[เพลง]
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ก็แค่แบบดูคือคนบางคนน่ะนะเล็มเห็นคนที่
เป็นนักร้องนำน่ะ
ตอนที่เขาไม่ได้ร้องเพลงนะ
เขาดูแบบไม่น่าสนใจเลยอ่ะดูแบบธรรมดามาก
ไม่สนใจเลยอ่ะแต่พอแบบจับไหมขึ้นมาแล้ว
ร้องเพลงแล้วแบบเฮ้ยเป็นคนที่แบบมีเสน่ห์
มาก
[เพลง]
คนเราเนี่ยจะดูแบบดูแบบมีเสน่ห์ดูแบบดี
บางคนน่ะก็เกิดจากการได้ทำในสิ่งที่ชอบ
ใช่ๆก็เพื่อนของคุณนิคเนี่ยที่เขาเป็นนัก
ร้องนำนะมีคนนึงคือถ้าปกติเขาจะเป็นคนที่
เงียบๆไม่ค่อย
ไม่คือคือสำหรับคุณนิคนะคุณนิกมองว่าคน
ที่อยู่ในวงดนตรีจะเป็นคนที่ชอบเข้าสังคม
มีเพื่อนเยอะ
ปาร์ตี้หรือ
ไปไหนที่ไม่ได้อยู่ตัวคนเดียวแต่
เพื่อนของคุณนิดคนนี้ที่เขาเป็นนักร้องนำ
เนี่ยเขาจะอยู่คนเดียวไม่เชิงว่าอยู่คน
เดียวแต่เขาจะเป็นคนเงียบๆไม่ค่อยพูดเยอะ
ไม่ค่อยพูดเยอะเหมือนเป็นคนที่โลกส่วนตัว
สูงเป็น introvert อะไรประมาณนั้น
ถามว่าเขาก็มีเพื่อนแต่เขาก็จะอยู่ด้วย
กันกับเพื่อนที่เล่นดนตรีแค่นั้น
มันก็แล้วแต่คนเนี่ยเนอะบางคนก็เป็นคนที่
แบบเออชอบคุยจริงๆ
ชอบแบบอยู่ในสังคมชอบพูดคุยกับคนอื่น
แล้วเหมือนครูนี้เคยเล่าให้เรียมฟังว่า
รุ่นนี้เคยแบบหัดตีกลองไหม
เคยไหมเคยเคยแต่ก็จะเป็นการตีกลองตีกลอง
ที่แบบตีกลองเล่นๆอ่ะ
คือมันเป็นกลองที่เหมือนของเล่นเด็กอ่ะ
สำหรับคนที่คิดว่าเป็นของเล่นเด็กแล้วคุณ
ก็จะไปตีตีไปแย่งไปแย่งหลานเล่นไปแย่งดู
เพื่อนเล่น
คนนี้ก็เลยไม่รู้หรอกว่าคุณนิกอ่ะเต้น
เป็นไหม
เพราะเราก็ไม่ได้เรียนนะแต่เราแค่แบบลอง
ดูแล้วก็อาจจะไม่ได้ชอบด้วย
ก็เลยแบบรู้สึกเฉยๆหรือเปล่า
คุณนิคชอบแต่คุณนิครู้ว่าคนนี้จะทำได้ไม่
ดีมันก็เลยเออลองก็ดีอยากรู้ว่าเป็นยังไง
แต่
ก็
มันก็ไม่ได้ง่าย
[เพลง]
เวลาที่แบบเราเห็นคนอื่นทำได้แล้วทำได้ดี
แล้วในส่วนของเราเนี่ยเราก็เอามาเปรียบ
เทียบนะว่าเราทำไม่ได้เรียมก็เลยคิดว่า
เออคนนั้นน่ะเก่ง
เพราะว่าเหมือนแบบเอามาเปรียบเทียบกับตัว
เองว่าเรียมทำไม่ได้
เรียนตีกลองไม่ได้รินก็เลยมองคนตีกลองว่า
เก่ง
เราก็เลยจะไปแบบในแบบเก่งจังเลยเก่งจัง
เลยอะไรอย่างนี้
แล้วสำหรับครูเรียมเนี่ยถ้าเลือกได้อยาก
เล่นดนตรีอะไร
หรืออยากทำอะไรเกี่ยวกับ
ดนตรี
อย่างกับทำอะไรเกี่ยวกับดนตรีคือตอนแรก
เตรียมอยากเล่นกีต้าร์แล้วเรียนก็ได้เล่น
แล้วนะได้เล่นกีต้าร์แล้ว
ตอนนี้
อยากตีกลอง
ใช่ไปดูใน YouTube มาแล้วก็แบบเฮ้ย
เป็นคนที่มีพลังงานเยอะมาก
แล้วก็เลยคิดว่าตีกลองนี่แหละ
มีวันนึงมีวันนึงที่ดู YouTube ไปแล้วก็
แบบเหมือน
ทำมือแบบนี้ทำมือแล้วก็โยกหัวไปด้วยนะโยก
หัวไปด้วย
ไปตามเราเพลิน
ให้สรุปปวดคอ
ไม่มีกลองนะแต่ปวดคอเพราะ
เป็นช่วงชีวิตวัยนึงนะที่แบบเราได้เห็น
แบบเพื่อนๆได้ทำอะไรที่สนุกพี่ๆได้ทำอะไร
ที่สนุกแล้วเราก็คิดว่าเออมันเป็นแรง
บันดาลใจสำหรับหลายๆคนใช่
ที่แบบเฮ้ยอยากทำแบบนี้เหมือนกัน
ของ
จริงๆของครูนิดเนี่ยคุณนิ
คุณจะคุณนิดอยากลองเล่นดนตรีที่จะไม่ได้
อยู่ในวงดนตรีที่เล่นคอนเสิร์ตแต่คุณนี้
จะสนใจเกี่ยวกับวงโยมากกว่า
วงโยก็คือเหมือนกับชื่อเต็มๆมันก็เรียก
ว่ายกวงโยธวาทิตใช่ไหมแล้ววงโยก็คือที่มี
เครื่องดนตรีใหญ่ๆเราจะเห็นบ่อยคือคุณนิ
ไม่รู้ว่าที่โรงเรียนอื่นเป็นยังไงแต่ตอน
ที่คุณนิคอยู่ในโรงเรียนคุณนิดเขาจะมีวง
โยตอนเช้า
เพลงชาติไทยเพลงชาติ
มีวงโยธวาทิตมา
วงโยธวาทิตของครูนิคโรงเรียนครูนิดมี
ประมาณกี่คนที่อยู่ในวงเดียวกัน
น่าจะซักประมาณ 20
ได้มั้งครับ
เป็นหลักสิบคนนะใช่เป็นหลักสิบคนก็วง
โยธวาทิตเนี่ยจะมีคนเยอะมากแล้วเขาก็จะ
แบบเรียงแถวอ่ะ
ตรงๆเลยนะ
สวยๆ
เพราะว่าครูนิคจำได้ว่าวงโยโรงเรียนคุณ
นิคเนี่ยคนที่เล่นเนี่ยไอ้ตัวเครื่องเป่า
ใหญ่ๆเนี่ยตัวเล็ก
แต่เขาก็เล่นได้
ใช่
แต่ว่าได้อยู่ในวงโยได้ไหม
คนนี้ไม่ได้อยู่
เพราะว่า
เหมือนวงโยเนี่ยเขาจะรับสมัครสำหรับคนที่
มีประสบการณ์เท่านั้น
คนที่เคยเล่นแต่คุณนิจะตั้งแต่เรียนเนี่ย
ไม่เคยเล่นเลย
คนนี้ถ้าเกิดเอาแบบนั้นน่ะเครื่องดนตรี
ที่ใหญ่ๆที่บ้านเรียมก็ไม่มีนะ
เรียนจบเรียนก็คิดว่าเรียนก็ไม่มี
ประสบการณ์นะที่จะแบบมาเป่าอะไรใหญ่ๆที่
บ้านก็แบบที่บ้านก็ไม่มีค่ะแบบ
ไม่มีประสบการณ์ค่ะแต่ว่า
ตอนที่เรียนเรียนอยู่ในโรงเรียนนะเรียนก็
อยู่ในวงโยธวาทิตด้วยนะ
ที่มันแบบมีสายสายแล้วก็แบบเหมือนเป่า
หรือว่าจะเป่าที่เครื่องก็ได้แล้วก็กด
เมโลเดียนโอเคโอเค
จำไม่ได้แล้วว่าเขาเรียกว่าเมโลเดียน
ใช่นั่นแหละแล้วแบบโรงเรียนของเรียนมัน
ไม่ใช่โรงเรียนใหญ่มากมันเป็นโรงเรียน
เล็กๆแต่ถ้าเกิดโรงเรียนใหญ่เขาน่าจะมี
แบบพวกทำเป็นอะไรแบบ
เออแบบนั้นน่ะที่แบบอันใหญ่ๆก็มีมีทำแต่
มีพวก
เขาเรียกว่าทำเป็ดทำโบนหรือเปล่าใช่ไหม
แล้วก็
กลองใหญ่ๆที่เหมือนจะมันตี 2 ข้างได้อะไร
ประมาณนี้มั้งใช่ๆอันนั้นก็คือวงโยธวาทิต
แบบวงใหญ่ๆเลย
แต่ของเรียมนี่เป็นวงเล็กๆ
ก็อยู่ในนั้น
มันน่าสนใจคิดว่ามันมัน
คือคนต้องเก่งที่ว่าเล่นเราจำได้จำโน๊ต
ได้
เราแถมอีกอย่างนึงวงโยธวาทิตเนี่ยต้อง
เดินไปด้วยแล้วก็เล่นดนตรีไปด้วย
แล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงถ้าพูดถึงเกี่ยวกับวง
ดนตรีเนี่ย
ที่คุณนิดชอบคุณนิดจะชอบดูพวกวงพวก
orchestra ที่มันจะอยู่บนเวทีเยอะๆ
อันนั้นน่ะคนนี้จะชอบ
ที่โรงเรียนครูนิดมีเหรอคะหรือว่าแบบไป
เจอตอนไหนจริงๆไม่ได้ก็คือตอนแรกเคยคือ
เจอในหนังคิดว่าครูเรียมน่าจะเคยดูหนัง
ไทยที่เรื่องเอ่อ
ใช่
ชื่อไทยเรียกว่าอะไรนะเพราะอากาศ
เป็นชื่อเพลง
รู้สึกว่าเออสนใจเกี่ยวกับพวก orchestra
ที่เขาเล่นกันแล้วมันมีเครื่องดนตรีเยอะ
เราใช้เป็นพวกไวโอลินอันนั้นก็จะเป็น
เครื่องดนตรีของทางฝรั่งไปเลยอ๋อใช่ในบาง
โรงเรียนก็จะมีวงออกคริสตัล
แต่ว่าจริงๆแล้วใช่ๆเพราะว่า
สมัยนู้นนะตอนที่หนังออกมาใหม่ๆเนี่ยตัว
นี้แค่รู้ว่ามีที่มหิดลเพราะว่าเหมือน
มหิดลก็จะมีเหมือนเป็นโรงเรียนทางดนตรี
โดยเฉพาะสำหรับมปลาย
ใช่ที่แบบมหาลัยมหิดลก็คือแบบมีชื่อเสียง
ด้านดนตรีมากเลยนะ
ใช่ๆ
เตรียมก็เคยคุยกับนักเรียนที่เขาเป็นนัก
ดนตรี
เล่นดนตรีเขาก็บอกว่าเขาก็จบมาจากมหิดล
นั่นแหละคือมาจากประเทศอื่นนะแต่มาเรียน
ดนตรีที่มหาวิทยาลัย
มหิดล
ที่เป็นเพื่อนที่ไม่ได้เป็นคนไทยเขาก็บอก
ว่าอยากมาเรียนที่มหิดล
[เพลง]
หลายๆคนในที่นี้ที่ฟังอยู่นะคะก็อาจจะเอา
สิ่งที่เราคุยกันไปคิดถึงว่าเราเคยอยู่ใน
วงดนตรี
ที่ไหนหรือเปล่าเป็นช่วงที่เรียนหรือว่า
ที่ทำงานหรือว่าตอนนี้
แล้ว
เราเคยเห็นหรือว่าเคยอยู่ในวงดนตรีแบบไหน
บ้างอาจจะเป็นวงดนตรีสากลที่เป็นเรื่อง
กีต้าร์ตีกลองหรือว่าเป็นวงโยธวาทิต
หรือว่ามีวงออเคสตร้า
ที่เราไม่รู้
จริงๆเราอ่ะไม่ได้คุยเกี่ยวกับวงดนตรีไทย
เลยนะ
ครับ
[เพลง]
คุณนิคน่าจะเล่นได้ดีเพราะว่ามันไม่ได้
มันก็มาแค่ตีๆๆกระทบกระทบไม้ไป
ทำง่ายๆนะ
ไม่ง่ายเรียมเคยแบบไปตีเล่นอยู่แล้วก็แบบ
ไม่เอา
ใช่แล้วก็ผ่านไปก็เลยลืมไงลืมวงดนตรีไทย
จบแล้วหมดเวลาแล้วด้วยค่ะทุกคน
เดี๋ยวไว้เอาอย่างนี้ครั้งต่อไปถ้าเรามี
เวลาเราจะพูดเกี่ยวกับวงดนตรีไทยนิดหน่อย
ว่า
ได้เลยแต่ว่าวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้
ได้งั้นเราไว้เจอกันใหม่ครั้งต่อไป
ได้เลยค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]